j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter à zuma
j'aime bien alors à zuma et a les yeux
bleus les cheveux bleus aussi avec ses
surnoms à zuma est plutôt sexy à zuma
est japonaise et c'est typiquement le
monde dans lequel on est en train de
vivre aujourd'hui à zuma n'est pas du
tout un manga azuma aujourd'hui c'est
une intelligence artificielle
combiné à un hologramme qui est vendu
2500 euros au japon pour être la femme
parfaite
je jure un truc de dingue
elle vous envoie des textos comment vas
tu darling à quelle heure rentres tu ce
soir je m'ennuie de toi
typiquement le genre de textos qu'on
peut avoir à longueur de temps dans des
échanges dans un couple essaie des
choses qui sont totalement normal au
japon à zuma a bien plus que cela bien
entendu c'est une intelligence
artificielle dont vous pouvez converser
avec elle vous regarder la télévision
elle regarde la télévision à côté de
vous elle commente ce qui peut énerver
pas mal de monde
un zoom à se plaint mais azuma contrôle
aussi la totalité de votre maison la
lumière est capable d'allumer elle four
de vous donner des recettes de cuisine
bref c'est ce qu'on appelle une
assistante personnelle au même titre que
certains d'entre vous ont dû connaître
amazon échos ou google home qui sont les
grands les grandes assistante
personnelle dont on a énormément parlé
ces derniers mois sur le web summit le
csa las vegas vous savez tous ces grands
salons mondiaux
l'idée c'est quoi c'est à terme de se
retrouver dans ça c'est pas si vous vous
souvenez ce film c'est un film qui en
lui-même le fus les potins
mais c'est un film qui a l'intelligence
de nous projeter dans la guerre actuelle
des grands gaf a c'est à dire la guerre
sur ce que sera l'intelligence
artificielle de l'assistante personnelle
à moins de 5 ans
ils sont tous en train de se battre pour
que vous puissiez à longueur de temps
que ce soit amazon avec et comac le soft
avec cortana ou aux trains commandés
vous puissiez avoir des conseils que
vous puissiez être dans une multitude de
situations où vous êtes baby cité du
matin au soir avec une interaction
exactement comme ceux vous discutez avec
votre pote aux parents ou je sais pas
quoi
cependant tout ça est basé sur une
multitude de points et j'aimerais bien
revenir avec vous sur ces différents
points
deux choses intelligence artificielle et
émotion
si vous vous souvenez de ce film vous
avez tous vu ce film
les quelques acquis sont paumés dans le
film bon alors pour vous la faire simple
quelqu'un vient de se faire larguer il
est déprimé il ya une intelligence
artificielle dans votre smartphone qui
lui est proposé et il interagit tombe
amoureux d'elle et se retrouve je peux
vous spoiler
oui la fin du film ça va à peu près bref
puis se retrouve amoureux d'aller se
rend compte que il n'y a plus d'une
dizaine de millions de personnes qui
sont exactement dans la même relation
d'amour avec une intelligence
artificielle
bref ça nécessite deux choses un niveau
d'intelligence artificielle qui bien
entendu aujourd'hui n'est pas celui
capable de donner ce genre d'interaction
humaine et deuxièmement la notion
d'émotion parce que ça veut dire qu'il
faut avoir des émotions pour être
capable de refaire ressentir des
émotions et la suite j'aimerais qu'on
ait une discussion assez assez précise
sur la notion d'émotion parce que on
parle d'un ordinateur un ordinateur cédé
1 et des zéros à longueur de temps
un ordinateur et n'est pas censé avoir
des émotions un ordinateur 6 ans et quel
que soit l'ordinateur répondre à des
lignes de codes qui effectuent des
commandes
or dès le moment où on considère qu'il
ya des émotions considère par définition
est bien que l'ordinateur ces lignes de
codes vont d'être dans une discussion
avec elle même dans un cadre une
capacité à ressentir à voir ou à faire
une multitude de choses l'intelligence
artificielle
aujourd'hui 1 à une multitude on va dire
deux sous catégories l'une des sous
catégories s'appelle le diplôme ning
pour vous la faire simple c'est tous les
combats actuels que vous
voir sur facebook google amazon
quand vous avez dit mind la division
intelligence artificielle de google qui
bat le champion du monde 2 go comme ça
s'est passé il ya il y a un peu moins la
mort puisque c'est en avril dernier
c'est mon seul regret bon c'est de
l'intelligence artificielle
cependant je ne sais pas si certains
d'entre vous jouez au jeu de go ça n'a
rien à voir avec le jeu d'échecs et la
performance d ibm
il y a maintenant quasiment 30 ans
puisque c'était un petit peu moins simon
je dirais que c'est des années 90 et 95
avec et sparrow les échecs c'est des
maths
vous êtes bon en maths vous avez la
route et vous êtes capable de prévoir
les 3/4 prochain coup c'est donc simple
pour un ordinateur entre guillemets le
jeu de go c'est de l'intuition
vous pouvez faire ce que vous voulez
c'est de l'intuition il y a des dizaines
de millions de combinaisons qui font que
ce n'est pas des mathématiques
il faut être capable de ressentir de
prévoir au sens du feeling il y a eu une
compétition il ya maintenant quelques
quelques semaines de poker je suis nulle
au poker sur vous pour vous mais c'est
la grande mode des poker et il est une
compétition des meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux contre une intelligence
artificielle
j'ai beau être nulle au poker il ya une
chose que je sais très bien ce poker il
faut bluffé
si vous ne le fait pas vous n'êtes pas
capable derrière en gros de faire passer
des coûts et gagner de l'argent
la capacité de bluffer démontre bien la
capacité que l'on peut avoir ni humain
ou autres un ordinateur dans ce cas-là
d'anticiper les émotions de la personne
que vous avez en face de vous et au delà
des émotions vous allez anticipé de vous
même paraître une certaine catégorie
d'émotion pour avoir un résultat des
autres joueurs en fonction de votre main
ou de ce que vous voulez obtenir c'est
bien un début d'émotion
là on est vraiment dans une discussion
et dans des rapports qui moi me me font
réfléchir de manière importante
on est aujourd'hui dans une situation où
je sais pas si certains d'entre vous
lisent énormément la presse j'ai des
souvenirs
il y a quelques années d'un jeune homme
qui a été emprisonné parce qu'il avait
eu le malin plaisir de prendre des bébés
chatons et de les éclaté contre des murs
il a été emprisonné pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui sur le plan juridique on
considère que l'animal à une entité
et que faire mal à un animal par
définition est juridiquement
répréhensible mais au-delà de ça je sais
pas si vous avez des animaux
moi j'en ai à la maison j'ai des amis
qui en ont c'est un truc de dingue alors
entre les psys entre la viande qui
acheté par certains certaines mamans
parce que c'est c'est le chien le chat
sait on par la db on a rapport aux
animaux quitte un rapport absolument
dingue
pourquoi parce qu'on a énormément
d'amour des animaux il ya bien une
émotion dans le cadre des animaux vous
souriez l'animal va voir que vous
souriez vous êtes mal je vous garantis
que votre peau d'chien va pas être bien
dans les dents les élèves qui suivent le
point que je veux vous dire il est qu'
on a des on va dire des critères liés à
l'émotion sur des animaux qui doivent de
manière logique être les mêmes critères
vis-à-vis de la machine si on veut être
cohérent et bien à partir de là on
commence à avoir une réflexion qui est
une réflexion importante c'est quoi de
l'émotion ça va être la précis de la
capacité avoir la capacité à entendre et
autres les fameuses division de google
et autres de 10 berning vous donne la
capacité en tant qu'ordinateur en tant
qu'entité électronique
à voir sur une photo à entendre à parler
bref à interagir au delà de simplement
de lignes de code
ça c'est bien début d'émotion cependant
il ya une différence entre la notion d'
émotion et la notion de conscience parce
que vous pouvez avoir des émotions c'est
pas pour autant que vous êtes dans une
situation de conscience alors je peux
vous la faire en cours le feu
fille mais basique mans conscience c'est
d'avoir conscience soi même et d'être un
petit peu dans une situation où on se
voit vous voyez imaginez vous un petit
peu en hauteur et vous voyez voir
vous-même réagir par rapport à quelque
chose
interagir par rapport à quelque chose
ressentir des choses j'ai une chaîne qui
gourmande j'avais deux chaînes
je vous garantis que survenait un os à
l'une l'autre bavé mais n'avait pas pour
une lotion de jalousie elle bat vais
juste ce qu on avait envie elle avait
envie de le manger cette hausse est bien
ce que je vous dis sur des notions qui
sont des notions liées à des animaux sur
les choses qui sont totalement
envisageable sur des machines
allons un peu plus loin est-ce que vous
sauviez ce film ex machina
c'est un film un peu terrifiant l'idée
c'est en gros d'être capable de donner
des émotions au sens du code dans ce
film-là en tous les cas d'une
intelligence artificielle et de voir sur
le fameux test de turing
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas c'est
un test qui vous permet vous en tant
qu'humain devoirs ou d'être capable de
sentir si la personne avec laquelle vous
interagissez de manière électronique en
face de vous êtes une personne physique
comme nous ou une intelligence
artificielle
le jour où l'intelligence artificielle
sera capable de passer ce test de turing
avec succès ça veut dire qu'on sera plus
capable nous en tant qu'humain de faire
la différence entre un homme et une
machine avec lesquels on parle cependant
est ce que quand vous tombez amoureux de
quelqu'un est ce que quand vous êtes
dans une situation de sentiments par
rapport à quelqu'un ça dépend de la
capacité à la personne avec laquelle
vous êtes d'avoir des émotions où ça
dépend de la capacité des personnes à
vous faire ressentir des émotions
deux exemples qui vont vous parler ce
film nous sommes aujourd'hui mi mars
vous avez un grand festival mondial mx
entre de la musique et de la technologie
à austin aux états unis ils ont lancé en
même temps que le film
vous savez ces fameux chat bottes
aujourd'hui dont on parle énormément
vous interagissent
vous avez des personnes qui vous parle
par facebook par sap et autres ils ont
lancé ses services
on va dire électronique sur l'ensemble
des invités de ce salon à austin sur
tender avec une capacité sur tinner à
interagir avec la personne en face une
jolie fille est vraiment très jolie
fille qui vous répondez c'était un brave
qui vous aguicher la majorité des mais
on est très content des mecs et donc la
majorité des mecs se sont retrouvés dans
une situation où ils n'ont pas compris
jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait la promotion du
film
il parlait à une machine je vous parle
de ça il y a quelques années
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
absolument folle vous êtes en famille
votre grand mère décède vous avez vous
souvenez ces séries actuellement sur les
robots human et j'ai un souvenir d'une
deuxième série qu on m'a souvent qu on
demandé de regarder black mirror
on est typiquement dans ce genre de
choses aujourd'hui qui sont bluffantes
en positif comme le font en ligue 1 vous
l'avez pas la capacité en tant qu'enfant
de discerner on va dire parce que vous
êtes en train de grandir une multitude
de choses
quelle va être la différence entre une
personne humaine ou un robot qui va être
capable de vous dire ce qui est bien ce
qui n'est pas bien qui va être capable
de s'occuper de vous qui va être capable
de vous envoyer des messages brefs de
vous donner de l'amour pour des enfants
pour une multitude de personnes
cette notion là n'est pas liée à la
capacité du robot ou de l'intelligence
avoir des émotions mais bien la capacité
à vous donner ce dont vous avez besoin
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un monde où
les gens sont seuls ou les gens sont
désespérément besoin de se retrouver
dans une situation où ils ont des gens
qui s'occupent d'eux qui lui donne des
émotions qui les font vibrer eh bien ça
aujourd'hui l'intelligence artificielle
est capable de le faire de la même
manière que nous sommes capables
aujourd'hui de tomber amoureux de nos
animaux et d'être totalement déprimée
parce que nos animaux sont malades
imaginez la fameuse jeune fille dont je
vous ai parlé japonaise de démarrage
qu'ils soient une personne physique
imaginez les rapports de l'homme
japonais à longueur de temps travaillant
comme des malades et qui va avoir à
longueur de temps
cette relation d'une personne qu'elle
soit physique ou pas qui va s'occuper de
lui par définition nous sommes des
humains nous allons développer des
sentiments pour eux et bien la réalité
est que on va se retrouver dans un monde
à moins de 5 ans quitte un monde
extrêmement intéressant est extrêmement
flippant d'une certaine manière où on va
être capable de développer des relations
des émotions avec des machines qui elle
même ne seront pas tout de suite en
capacité d'elle-même développer des
machines et des émotions mais ça va
créer chez nous des maladies et c'est
d'ailleurs très bien envisager
aujourd'hui par les grandes cher de
cambridge stanford et autres qui ont
créé des chaire de psychologie pour
étudier l'impact que vont avoir les
émotions de la relation homme machine et
les maladies associées
mais j'aimerais un petit peu plus loin
juste pour terminer et vous faire
réfléchir
voici une image qui m'a énormément
interpellé c'est un rêve de
l'intelligence artificielle de google
voici une autre image
quand nous rêvons nous mixons une
multitude de choses
l'intelligence artificielle selon vous
selon beaucoup de gens c'est des lignes
de code
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que on
n'est pas sur des lignes de code
on est sur un schéma où on apprend à
l'ordinateur à apprendre c'est à dire
que l'ordinateur se développe lui même
et s'adapte en fonction des situations
la vraie problématique elle est là nous
allons être à 15 ans dépasser par
l'intelligence artificielle en termes de
puissance et de réflexion on va dire
cérébrale on va être dans une situation
où typiquement des personnes comme
stephen hopkins nous ont considéré
aujourd'hui comme étant potentiellement
à la fin de l'humanité à cause
simplement de notre incapacité à suivre
l'intelligence artificielle mais la
vraie problématique n'est pas du tout
l'intelligence artificielle la vraie
problématique c'est les émotions
parce que si vous avez typiquement
aujourd'hui un schéma ou un ordinateur
va être capable que ce soit par
mimétisme ou autres d'apprendre à
développer des émotions
on va se retrouver dans toute la
différence qui va y avoir entre des
robots qu'ils ont un qui vont être dans
notre quotidien de manière extrêmement
importante à 10 ans qui suivront deux
ordres et des rebonds qui étant donné
qu'ils ont développé des émotions on se
retrouver dans une situation où vont ce
qu'ils vont se poser la question
pourquoi je suis ces instructions mettre
en doute ces émotions là est bien aussi
bien que l'intelligence artificielle les
émotions pondre absolument merveilleuse
pour nous dans le futur
on a aussi à se poser aujourd'hui la
question du pacte de mariage qui peut y
avoir entre nous la machine et son
intelligence artificielle
si mon souvenir est bon le mariage c'est
pour le meilleur et pour le pire
et aujourd'hui on est plutôt dans la
voie du pire merci vous
[Applaudissements]